my name is NaN short i'm from similar
web similar web is a web company that
helps marketers go and win in the online
marketing world we basically solve a
major problem of understanding what your
competitors are doing in digital world
what's working for them and what's not
working for them how how do they grow
what people are doing in the website or
in the mobile app and we're walking with
Fortune 500 companies with startups we
really love to help people grow and win
in digital world
before joining similar web I was CEO of
a company called tap dog we were
actually competing with similar web and
then similar web acquired us I became
head of innovation and head of US
operations for singular web and since
then I'm working with a lot of companies
advising them about the marketing
strategy about how to win and how to go
and having a lot of fun when you're
starting with social media you got to
have a goal in mind what exactly are you
trying to do don't just try to do social
media for the sake of it because you
want to get more users you got you want
to get them to buy something you want to
retain them you want to remind them that
you're there you want you want to
promote an event what do you want to do
and then after you decide what you want
to do you need to associate it with the
content that you're creating and it's I
can't stress it enough how important it
is to a source to correlate your voice
the context the content and the actual
platform so let's say that you're a
small startup that is trying to sell
closing does it make sense to you to be
present on on LinkedIn and keep updating
them the medium sometimes is more
important than the actual message one
more thing is localization let's say
that you have a huge user base in Brazil
or in China or in India or in Russia
there are specific social network that
exists there and there are more popular
than Facebook you want to have presence
there because you can acquire a lot of
users from there obviously you need to
use the language that they speak in
those countries but the ROI on using
those those social networks can be
amazingly high
another thing is to treat websites like
Stack Overflow or github or even where
it's like social network because if you
have a presence there that you keep
maintaining and you'll keep posting
interesting stuff you're educating or
entertaining your users people will keep
exploring who is this user who is who is
the president who is the company behind
this amazing social present and you'll
get even more value for your for your
money for your efforts then you will get
on Twitter on Facebook or tumblr or
whatever you being present today one of
the most important things when you're
doing your content marketing strategy is
first of all don't look at the process
as creating content or creating
inventory that's a recipe for failure
because you don't want just to create
content for the sake of it you want to
create stuff that people will actually
like and the best way to do something
like that is to try to imitate the way a
newspaper walk you want to get
interesting content something that keeps
people treated some of the people would
like to read and then produce it dot
don't measure your content creators
based on number of words
measure them based on the engagement
that they can create after they publish
their content and all of you will get
the same thing the same number of likes
clicks whatever you would like to
measure it with but eventually that's
the best the best steady way to measure
the success of a content marketing
marketing strategy another example of
great content marketing strategy is
buffer
for example buffer is a b2c to be
company basically that gives you the
ability to schedule your tweets schedule
your Facebook your Facebook updates and
schedule your social activity and their
blog which is one of the most popular
blogs in in tech has nothing to do with
the product it has something to do with
productivity with being transparent with
your employees with being a better
person and people that has don't even
know that they have a company that they
have a product keeps keep following this
blog
and this works amazingly one of the
things that that we do it's similar web
that and we did in tap dog is following
the activity of companies following
what's going on on the Internet and the
best way to understand what you want to
write about what kind of content you
want to create is checking it out so one
of the things that we do in similar web
in order to create content that engage
people is to track the trends that are
currently happening on the internet if
it's the actual emedicine rich or if
it's Netflix P what people are watching
on Netflix today new products new
investments new the poke visit to the to
new york whatever and we write blog
posts about it we create content about
it because we see that people care about
and then if people see the content that
we create and they want to share it
because they want to feel smarter
because they want to educate their
friends or they want to entertain them
that's a huge win for every blog post
like that let's imagine if we will start
a pony we need to be scraping we need to
not use a lot of resources and get a lot
of traction a lot we need huge otherwise
so we invest a lot of time in creating
the content in crafting it but that
investment in understanding what people
care about understanding the specific
medium the specific timing and the
specific context that we're going to
release this content is everything for
us another example is a 24 before they
sold to Yelp and also after they have an
amazing blog they are the best and
entertaining people they create they I
think the blog is called ratchet ales or
something like that and they are using
it for rants about food and just
bragging about new stuff that they did
and they entertain their users in such a
way that you feel you feel better when
you're sharing some of their content
this is amazing